I am guilty of overusing the word brilliant.
It diminishes its value.
However,
if there was one person walking the earth today who is truly brilliant,
it is Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
It would not be a stretch to assume history.
We'll lump him in with soccer days,
Freud and young.
If you haven't yet gone down the JBP rabbit hole,
you may think I'm being hyperbolic,
but I assure you everything you've heard is true.
He is a cultural icon,
a phenomenon,
and possibly one of the smartest people alive today.
Formerly a Harvard professor,
Jordan Peterson is currently a clinical psychologist and professor at University
of Toronto and has become a celebrity in his own right,
which is a very,
very good thing for all of us as many in academia and the left seek to make
victims of anyone who isn't a white CIS gendered male providing safe spaces on
campus as so young adults never have to experience the horrors of being
offended.
Dr. Peterson has been speaking about the assault on the greatest liberal value
of all free speech.
You may have learned about him a couple of years ago when he ignited controversy
by refusing to use the long list of made up gender neutral pronouns that was put
into Canadian law.
Bill see 16 while he has no objections to trans people,
he argued forced speech under the guise of gender identity and gender expression
are too broad.
Are the propositions of radical social constructionists and are being used to
bully opponents into submission.
He says,
free speech is not just another value.
It's the foundation of Western civilization.
Well,
you may have just learned of Jordan Peterson from his recent interview with a
British third wave feminist who tried every way possible to cookie cut Peterson
as a misogynist.
The channel for interview in England with British journalists.
Kathy Newman went viral and now Dr Peterson's online videos and there are many
are being binged Netflix style.
I warn you,
you won't be able to watch just one.
He just released his new book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos,
which has rocketed to the number one or two depending upon the day on the Amazon
bestseller list.
Depends upon where that tabloid trash by.
Michael Wolff is today along with his new book,
it seems Jordan Peterson is ubiquitous.
His name is on everyone's lips.
I attended an event the other night and heard his name mentioned several times
throughout the evening by different people.
I learned about Jordan Peterson sometime back watching his interviews first on
Joe Rogan's podcast and subsequently on the countless speeches and lectures he
has given all which can be found on youtube.
In fact,
he has opened up his classes to the world for free all on line watching his
lectures.
You feel enlightened and amazed how he combines history,
psychology,
science,
sociology and philosophy into a very enjoyable and learn it experience.
There's so much I can say about Jordan Peterson and I don't want to sound like a
fan boy,
but it is truly an honor to have him join us today.
Obviously I'm not the only fan.
As he has had over 100 million hits on Youtube.
We opened up questions to ricochet members and we'll be asking you a few,
but like all good things,
there was never enough time.
So if we don't get to yours,
apologies,
but we hope to have Dr. Peterson back on again down the road.
So without further ado,
pour yourself your favorite drink.
Sit back and enjoy the whiskey politics interview with Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
First of all,
Dr. Peterson,
I want to thank you for joining us at whiskey politics on ricochet.
It really is an honor to have you with us,
especially how busy you are right now.
Now Watch me try and get an hour's worth of questions into 30 minutes.
You just let me know when you need to get off and we'll wrap it up.
Okay,
sounds good.
All right.
Thank you.
So your name is everywhere right now.
There are those of us who've been following you for some time,
but something happened in the past few months.
I don't know if it's the Kathy Newman interview that did it,
but everybody is talking about Jordan Peterson.
You wrote in your book,
you are always surprised.
People respond positively to what you're saying regardless or regarding the
seriousness of the subjects.
Why do you think people in the tens of millions are drawn to your message right
now?
What are they hungry for?
I think they are hungering for,
for,
I think they're hungry for evidence that the idea that their lives are
meaningful and worthwhile is actually true.
And I do think it's true,
and I detailed that extensively in my first book,
maps of meaning,
which is a very difficult book,
but then again in 12 rules for life.
I think that it's reasonable to make the observation that life is very difficult
and rife with suffering and tainted with malevolence.
But despite that there are in the world,
there are ways of being in the world that are noble and worthwhile and that
ameliorates suffering and,
and malevolence and that it's worthwhile to grow up and take your place in the
world as a responsible citizen.
And that the ideas of sovereign individuality that have,
that underpin the west are great ideas and correct and that we shouldn't lose
the.
And so I think that people are,
there's a whole in people's hearts the same shape as that message and so we may
hear it.
They feel like a part of them that they didn't know it was missing has been
replaced and so that's what it looks like to me.
Now you referred a lot of,
many of our listeners have been following you for some time and a lot of people
that just learning about you and you're known for detailing how postmodernism is
today's form of Marxism.
Is this what you're referring to here that people have had enough of the
postmodernist maybe cause they've taken over learning institutions?
Our media and culture?
Well that's part of it.
I think it's,
there's a deeper Malays do though is then we'd become unmoored from our
traditional foundations and the foundations let's say of Judaeo Christian
culture.
We don't understand them who probably never did,
but we acted demoed anyways before,
but we can't lose sight of that tradition without falling apart in 15 different
ways.
I think the postmodern way of falling apart,
it's just one of many,
but it's very toxic.
It divides us into tribes based on our ethnicity or our gender,
our race,
and then sets us against one another as oppressive versus victim.
And it's a very,
very pathological and dangerous narrative.
So,
and I think people know that instinctively,
they don't want to descend into tribal identities again,
but that means we needed it.
We needed an identity that is super ordinance to the tribal.
There has to be something above that.
And I think the idea of the sovereign individual is the right transcendent
representation.
And I think that people know that too,
because it's,
that message is everywhere in our culture,
even know it's not made as explicit as it should.
We're explicit as often as it should.
Yeah.
You talk about individualism,
me,
your message comes from the perspective of a classic liberal and individualism
is part of that.
Uh,
but the interesting thing,
you've not only been a student of Marxism,
communism and socialism,
I mean you really went deep into it.
Soviet gulags the rise of Nazi-ism and the Holocaust and you always refer to the
Gulag archipelago that the machine eats itself.
You relate today's postmodernist to that same machine.
Well,
I think they're driven by the same pathological ideology.
You can tell that by their emphasis on the impressive versus victim narrative,
which is classic Marxism is just give him new clothing.
You know,
it's not the bourgeoisie versus the protests.
Proletariat,
it's the oppressed minority versus the oppressive here.
Majority,
same basic idea and company,
not the demand for such impossibilities as equality of outcome,
which is unbelievably dangerous idea.
It's the same ideology.
It's just dressed up in more current clothing and it's,
it's,
it's going to lead to the same place,
so unless we want to go there,
which I wouldn't recommend since we've already visited and founded unpleasant,
it seems to me that we should pick a different path and dispense with the
identity politics both on the left and on the right and go back to what we got
right.
The thing that makes me a little different than the classic liberal,
I guess in some senses that there's probably more emphasis from the liberal land
on individual freedom.
Whereas I put a tremendous amount of emphasis on individual responsibility.
But the union between those two things would be the emphasis on the individual.
No.
So in 12 rules for life,
a lot of what I'm trying to inform people off,
let's say,
is that they can take on very heavy responsibility for life in all of its
tragedy and let's malevolence and prevail and that that's what they should do.
And that's the right way to set the world straight.
It's the honorable way.
It's the noble way.
And it works too.
It's not,
it's not naive optimism.
I'm not a naive optimist.
I know how terrible the world is,
but I still think that we can,
we can live in it like admirable beings and we can make it much better than it
is now.
We can start with ourselves and I think that's the right path forward.
Yeah.
And I,
and I want to get into 12 rules of life and they edit out to chaos,
um,
in a,
in a moment.
It's a fantastic book.
And,
and as of right now,
today,
it's number two on the Amazon bestseller list.
So congratulations on that.
But it sounds like you've,
you've,
and what I've read here,
you've surrounded yourself,
uh,
with,
with understanding this to the point where,
and I was a little surprised,
um,
you know,
Norman Doidge,
he wrote the forward in your book 12 rules of life and he says that you have an
expansive art collection of socialist realist paintings of Lenin and early
communists.
He explains it so that you never forget the hundreds of millions of people who
were murdered in the name of Utopia.
What about this ideology,
this horror,
if you will,
of human suffering that steered you into studying it?
No,
it seemed to me when I started studying it,
the 1980s,
we were still in the midst of the CEW award and hosted a genuine threat not only
to the lives of every individual on the planet,
but too well,
but to life itself.
And it seemed to me that there was no problem that required solving more urgent
urgently then the problem of pathological group identification and the conflict
that emerges out of it.
And the more,
I mean I,
I took,
I took what happened in Nazi Germany and did in the Soviet Union and malice
China with deep seriousness considering it,
what would you call it,
up a sign of the illness that be set all of humanity,
not just those countries and believe that there was no problem.
That was more,
it was more necessary to take seriously and to try to solve.
And so that's guided me since probably since the late 1970s I've put all my
effort and teaching pretty much into understanding group identification at a
psychological level,
trying to account for the ideological possession and then trying to figure out a
way through it so that people were neither nihilistic nor puppets of right or
left wing ideology trying to find out what the alternative to that was.
And I think that responsible individuality,
you know,
with respect for society and the group is the right,
I think we got the answer right in the west and I think that's why the West
isn't complete hell.
Like so many countries are so many places.
Are you concerned this wave authoritarianism is sweeping across North America?
I mean we see it in the schools.
You became famous obviously because of the Toronto,
uh,
University of Toronto was situation with a,
with the law for the transgender usage of words that you were forced to have to
say.
Uh,
I mean,
do the college administrators,
many of them who went at academia when they adverted the Vietnam war themselves,
does just the society just wait for them to all die off?
What does this end,
well that's a good question.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know what's going to happen with the universities because the humanities
are completely dominated by postmodern radical left cause it's,
I mean the documentation for that is clear.
Um,
I think what will happen is they'll just run out of the audience.
That's what I'm hoping will happen is that people will wake up and think,
oh Jesus,
this isn't education.
This is indoctrination and this is a pessimistic and pathological view of the
world.
All we'll do is produce increasing division and hatred between groups and we'd
go better things to do.
So I'm hoping that people will turn away from those disciplines in those
courses.
The problem is they often don't know that that's what they're going to be
exposed to.
But you know,
who has Lincoln said you can fool all of the people some of the time,
but you can't fool all of the people all of the time.
Right.
So can I hope,
I'm hoping that people are waking up and if they can find something better to do
with their lives than to become chronically resentful,
professional protesters and and instigators of group conflict under the name of
some kind of compassionate morality.
It's complete.
It's completely reprehensible as far as I can tell.
There's nothing in it's good.
Now it isn't to say that there's nothing to be said on the left side of the
political spectrum.
Like I know full well that inequality tends to grow and then as it grows,
it threatens the structure of society.
There has to be a voice for people who are on the dispossessed end of the
distribution.
And so I think there's a perfectly reasonable place for an informed left wing
who basically speaks for those who have not managed to be or who didn't have any
opportunity to be successful.
But that's not the same as dividing this up into identity groups based on gender
and eternally playing oppressive versus victim.
Right.
Our normal relations between human beings is what you're referring to the left
now trying to mediate that or do they want the state to mediate that?
What is their end game here?
Well,
I don't know.
The end game hypothetically is a state where of radical equality of outcome.
Nowhere no one has any more of anything than anyone else and also no less.
But that's a completely impossible goal.
That will never happen.
You know,
as I'm a sole pointed out,
if you give the state enough power to legislate equality of outcome,
you've also given the state enough power so that it is certain that it would
become a tyrant and I believe that.
But I think that there are people in the ideological camps,
both on the right on the left,
but we're talking about the left at the moment.
Who would be happy to see everything burned down as long as those who were
successful were destroyed along with it.
So there's,
that certainly happened in,
in,
in the Communist countries during the 20th century,
there was a tremendous underground sense of resentment and hatred that motivated
the destruction of whole classes of successful people.
Like the,
like the successful farmers,
the Kulaks that were all killed in the 1920s so
who knows what the end game is,
what they say,
what it is fairly straight forwardly yeah,
it's the destruction,
the patriarchy.
Well,
that speaks for itself.
You know,
what are the greatest quotes I've read from you is,
is human beings are born with different capacities.
If they are free,
they are not equal and if they are equal than they are not free.
I think that was originally Milton Friedman.
Oh,
was it Milton?
He so,
yeah.
Cool.
Melty.
Okay.
I think it's,
it's,
it's definitely the case.
Well,
the problem with equality of outcome arguments is well across what dimension are
you going to ensure that no one has any more friends than anyone else?
Well,
no one is going to have any more lovers or no one has a bigger art collection or
no one's better at playing music or has a larger library.
Where are you going to stop with the demands for equality?
There's no stopping place and people don't even want the same outcomes.
So it's
people are,
the thing about freedom is that people are free to be different.
No,
you know,
the price we pay for that to some degree is the inevitability of comparative
failure.
But the Marxists liked to blame inequality on capitalism.
And that's the one of the biggest technical mistakes they make because
inequality is the rule in natural and social systems alike.
So the populations are distributed equally in cities and mass is distributed
unequally in stars and trees are of different heights in the rain forest,
all following the same inequality distribution that characterizes,
say income or wealth.
In a,
in a human society,
the inequality problem is much deeper than it can't be laid at the feet of
capitalism.
It's a foolish analysis,
but,
but inequality is still a problem and it has to be dealt with.
So,
but the idea that it can be eradicated in some permanent forum and that the cure
would be better than the disease is naive at best,
willfully blind,
most certainly,
and malevolent in most cases.
It's mostly based on resentment and jealousy,
especially in North America because the typical person in North America is rich
beyond the wildest imaginings of people a hundred years ago.
You know?
So even if you're relatively poor in North America,
you have central heating,
you have running water,
you have computational technology that puts $1 trillion worth of information
every moment at your fingertips.
You know,
you're,
we're so rich.
Yeah.
And people don't have to worry about being torn apart by animals or freezing to
death or anything like that.
It's a big difference.
Yeah.
And it's very unlikely to.
So the other thing I've been trying to point out is that we should try to muster
up a little bit of gratitude for it.
What are the biggest challenges men and women both have is finding the perfect
gift for a man,
whether it's a significant other father,
son,
friend,
could be a coworker or your boss,
somebody you play golf with.
You know,
it's never easy to find that gift.
And many of us end up just getting a gift card and it's quick and it's easy,
but it's also quite boring.
And now with Valentine's Day coming up,
yeah,
you know,
we all realize it's a cheesy hallmark holiday,
but it doesn't mean that you have to get that guy at cheesy hallmark gift.
The solution is [inaudible] dot com it's the only place to find awesome gifts
that guys love.
Now it isn't some Cologne sampler or cheesy mug man offers a curated gift
collection for every type of guy.
There's different collections for the sports fanatic home chef and outdoorsman.
If you're interested in cigars or whiskey or beer,
check out classics like the NFL barware crate and the whiskey appreciation
crate,
or a fresh takes on traditional Valentine's day gifts like the jerky heart or
the Salami Bow k and it always cracks me up.
It looks good.
It looks really yummy.
You know?
Imagine you're a mad opening up a whole crate of Salami.
Go to man crates.com pick the perfect gift and then wait for that magic to
happen.
See,
what's going to happen is that it's going to be delivered literally in a crate,
hence the name,
and there's no way to open it unless they use a crowbar which happens to be
included.
So part of that gift is just getting a guy to get a box open with a crowbar cue.
The Tim Allen voice a voice,
they have thousands of five star reviews and every gift comes with a complete
satisfaction guarantee.
So go to [inaudible] dot com slash whiskey and you'll get 5% off.
They don't offer a discount anywhere else.
Get 5% off right now at [inaudible] dot com slash whiskey man [inaudible] dot
com slash whiskey
I have a few questions for you from ricochet members here.
Many of our ricochet members,
you pseudonyms.
So you might hear a couple of funny sounding names here,
but the first one doesn't.
His name is Brian Watt,
and he asks,
what do you think of the current pope and his apparent leaning?
Some might say anticapitalist pro socialists,
perhaps postmodernist outlook on life.
Does he find the current Catholic hierarchy helpful or a hindrance and standing
up against the wave of postmodernist,
neo Marxist indoctrination and propaganda throughout Western societies?
Okay.
I would say I probably don't know enough to really answer that question
intelligently.
It's necessary generally speaking,
for the Catholic Church to err on the side of compassion for the poor and
dispossessed so we could say,
well,
perhaps that's what the current pope is doing,
but I don't know enough about his doctrines and aims to provide a criticism
that's any more intelligent than that.
Okay.
A second one is from judge mental told you he had some great pseudonyms here.
Judgemental asks you,
what do you think will be the next battlefield?
We've gotten to the point where even gender is now set to be up for grabs.
What does it go from here?
Hmm.
There'll be babbling over whether or not scientific truth is acceptable as truth
or just another form of power,
power play power.
That's already happening.
Um,
there'll be in the soul to him the idea of qualitative diff distinctions per se.
The idea that one thing is better than another,
that'll come under attack and all sorts of different dimensions that's already
happening.
Um,
because the problem is,
is that if you allow for qualitative distinctions,
so if you allow for the suggestion that one thing is better than another,
then you rationalize the existence of inequality.
Because if one thing is better than another and people provide the better thing,
then you can make a case that they should succeed,
where others should fail,
and that produces inequality.
So the radical argument against inequality has to end in the destruction of the
idea of value distinctions themselves.
And I think that's part of,
that's built into postmodernism anyways.
That's the sacrifice they're willing to make.
So we're going to see more of an outright attack on biology,
especially evolutionary biology and psychology that's already happening.
Um,
and assault on the idea that scientific truth has some sort of privileged status
that's already happening.
So we'll see an assault on the idea that there's any such thing as an objective
of education that's already happening in Canada,
in Ontario with the elementary teachers,
federation has already decided that the purpose of education from kindergarten
to grade eight is to produce students with a social justice activist
orientation.
And they've even selected all the literature that the kids will be exposed to in
order to foster that India logical perspective.
I mean,
that's right out in the open and that's on their website.
It's part of the curriculum.
So,
so is this a devaluing of empirical evidence then that we just don't believe
anything anymore?
We believe what the postmodern ideas that you believe,
whatever fosters the interest of your group.
There's no truth above that.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's an absolutely dismal hypothesis.
Wow.
Now,
as people were asking questions of you,
uh,
in a,
in our forum and interesting discussion between ricochet members,
NFE and front seat cat occurred,
again,
pseudonyms occurred in,
in relation to your interview with Kathy Newman and pertaining specifically to
agreeableness.
Now remember Anna fee told her sister who was angry over not being paid as much
as a male coworker to go and make the case to her boss and demand more money.
Now I know anesthesia is a strong willed woman.
Now her sister felt her work should speak for itself and front seat cat,
another member agreed with NFE sister that she shouldn't have had to ask that
the raise was then about behavior and not about the quality of work.
You referred to agreeableness,
right,
and not gender as the reason people may not achieve their potential.
It's one of the reasons,
there's many reasons for pay differential,
but not only do you have to do good work,
you have to be seen to do good work and you have to make a case for it.
It's like in the best of all possible worlds.
He would sit back and your accomplishments would speak for themselves.
But that assumes that the people that you're talking to have enough time to even
pay attention to what you're doing and notice.
And that's often not the case,
especially if if you're a quiet worker and you're competent,
the price you pay for that is in visibility.
And people,
you'd think,
well,
people should notice what we're,
what we're doing and rewarded and they probably should.
But that doesn't mean that you lack all responsibility in making your case
known.
And most of the time a boss,
a manager who's busy doing 150 different things,
isn't going to
be alert constantly enough to make sure that your career is being fostered in
the optimal possible manner.
You might have to make a case.
Often people don't even know what you're doing if you're competent.
And so I think it's a very naive view of the world to say,
well,
my work should speak for itself.
It's like,
well,
the wouldn't be advertising if people's work could speak for itself.
And there wouldn't be marketing,
there wouldn't be sales,
you know?
And for most products,
sales,
marketing and advertising is like 75% of the product,
right?
So it's just naive and it's not like money is just laying around.
Everyone's after it.
It's in scarce supply.
And so if you want to develop your career,
if you have some notion about how much money you need to make,
then you have to go out there and,
and strategically employ a plan to obtain that
and learning how to promote yourself or stand up for yourself.
And you've referred to this in your book,
you're talking about standing up straight,
right?
I mean it's about having confidence and belief in yourself.
Yeah.
Well if you lunch also,
I also tell people in the book suggest to people that they consult the
resentments.
So let's say you're
working way madly at your job,
then you're very mouthy,
but less competent.
Coworker is getting paid more and it just starts to eat away at your heart and
to poison your relationship with your work.
Well,
what should you do about that?
No,
you should first of all notice that you're becoming resentful and then you
should ask yourself,
well,
am I just being whiny and neurotic and complaining?
Or is there an actually an injustice here?
And if the answer is there's actually an injustice,
then you have to make your case and you,
you do that so that you stop yourself from being resentful so that you can stay
happy to be going to work.
And so that you can set the institution straight.
You know,
justice doesn't appear of its own accord.
It's something you have to work for on your own behalf.
Comes on the behalf of others.
You know,
it's like the,
let's say you're a husband and you're a little bit too agreeable and you say
your wife doesn't,
um,
there's things that you need or want that your wife isn't providing.
You won't talk to her.
You say,
well,
if she really loved me,
she just know.
It's like,
no,
she's not omniscient and you're not transparent.
So you have to go and say,
look,
here's what I want.
You have to negotiate about it because maybe you don't get what you want.
But maybe you do,
here's what I want.
Here's what would satisfy me.
This is why it's important.
This is what we need to do.
And that's how you start the relationship from becoming an anachronistic and
corrupt.
And it's the same at work.
You always have to fight for justice,
always,
always.
And why not?
Of course,
you have to
some of your critics after that interview,
which went viral,
it's insane.
Uh,
they refer to you some of the critics and it's very few of them by the way,
that mostly in the media and academia they refer to as a massage earnest.
Yet you say the greatest threat to women is a weak man.
It seems.
Dr. Peterson,
we are surrounded by them today.
Are men becoming weaker?
Well,
men are constantly told that if they were just harmless,
the world would be a much better place if they were weakened few tile and you
know,
constrained older,
assertive and aggressive impulses and quit going out there and being so
patriarchal and all of that.
And it's mostly nonsense mean when you want for men is an extraordinary and
women as well as an extraordinarily high level of competence.
And most of our functional hierarchies are built on competence,
not power.
And why in the world would any woman want not want to have a man around who was
competent and less.
All she wanted was dumb to be dominant,
you know?
And some of them would like that because they're there,
they'd had their relationships with men damaged and they want to make sure that
anybody that's around them is under their thumb because they're afraid of,
while they're afraid of the alternative.
But it's not a good way to live.
And so this is how this whole,
this misogyny ideas just,
it's so absurd that it's,
it's,
it's evidence of something else.
I'm a reasonable person.
I don't approve of what the radical leftists are up to.
I know why what they're doing is pathological and where it's going to lead.
I make the case strongly and reasonably.
And because they have no defense of their ideas,
what they do is target me with all sorts of epithets.
Mean,
I've had dozens of women in my clinical practice who I've been hell,
I've helped them develop their careers like mad,
you know?
And a lot of these were high achieving women,
but not all of them.
Some of them were struggling along at the bottom.
We spend hours and hours all the time out how to strategize so they could move
themselves forward in their relationships and when they're in their careers,
in your education.
So the idea that I'm a misogynist,
it's like,
well,
whatever you,
you have your opinion about it and you have your reasons.
But um,
the fact that I'm helping men develop their competence hardly makes me an enemy
of women unless the woman who think that are so clueless that they think that
they would benefit
by having more weak men in the world.
And some people think that,
but it's foolish.
Last question on that for,
I watched the followup interview in Amsterdam.
I think it wasn't,
you obviously had decompressed a bit from the interview,
which was shortly before that and you said you felt somewhat bad that you did
the Gotcha moment further away from this.
You know,
a couple of weeks now in retrospect,
would you have said anything differently in that interview with her?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not unhappy with the interview and the idea with the Garcia was,
I was making a joke,
you know,
and yeah,
it was a wild time joking.
There's,
there's utility in the Joel Comm.
One of my friends pointed out that I could have used that as an opening to
starting a more detailed conversation,
a more serious conversation,
but we were pressed for time.
The interview was almost over.
It's useful to keep things to introduce some liberty where that's possible.
Um,
I think the interview went as well as I could have hoped.
Porn.
That's good enough.
Like,
you know,
going over it with a fine tooth comb.
I can think of things that I might've,
what broaches I might've taken.
It wouldn't be different,
but it isn't clear to me that that would have necessarily been
better.
Does it surprise you they turned her into her a victim?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it was actually quite shocking to me.
Yeah.
It can begin with because it was so,
it was so both predictable and preposterous.
It's like,
well,
she's a public figure.
She's hardly a victim.
She's,
it's not like she's without power or influence.
She's got plenty of it.
She's doing quite well financially too.
I imagine them on most,
on most dimensions of measurement.
Um,
but to try it out,
that victim narrative so rapidly was,
well,
first of all,
reprehensible and second of all,
appallingly predictable.
And it was quite shocking because when it first happened,
about 20 newspapers carried,
picked up the ball and ran with it,
you know,
mostly in Canada and in the UK,
but then a counter narrative develop pretty rapidly.
And,
uh,
you know,
it isn't clear that the victim narrative is the one that carried the day.
So
I don't think it,
I don't think it carried the day,
but it was certainly voiced out there.
And you know what,
what do they say when you have ink by the barrel?
They're going to be the loudest ones.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
so,
uh,
last question.
Uh,
you're,
you're obviously a Canadian,
but you have your
pulse on American politics.
And Ricochet is a right of center site and community.
In one of your speeches,
you thought the vote for Trump was people basically just saying they had enough.
Were you surprised by the election?
Yeah,
a month before that I was certain that Clinton was going to win.
I was shocked by the election.
But the thing is the Americans that mean split 50,
50 for about 15 years.
So,
and it was really no different than that.
The split between the population is so close that,
you know,
minor perturbations can throw it one way or another.
And I do think that identity politics was one of the factors that elected Trump
people had just had enough of it.
So I guess I was surprised because I didn't regard Trump as a particularly
credible,
um,
potential leader.
And I,
you know,
it's not like I was alone in that estimation,
but,
um,
I guess people,
I think people decided they preferred the impulsive lies of Trump to the
calculated lies of Clinton.
You need more honest lies.
Wait,
what are your thoughts thus far?
Um,
I'm refraining from judging.
Look,
North Korea.
So look good for the good and the world hasn't fallen apart.
So I'm always amazed when not hasn't happened.
So hopefully that will continue.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's good.
Go.
I'm,
I've got another meeting coming up right away and my people around here getting
all agitated because I'm talking,
we're not shape moving.
Some doctor talked to Jordan Peterson.
It's been a treat.
Talking with you today.
Would love to continue to discuss this discussion with you soon.
Thank you so much for your time.
Yeah,
well thanks very much for the invitation and it was good talking with you.
Thank you.
Take care.
All right.
Bye.